au coeur du village des prêts la rue
bertin pourrait ressembler à n'importe
quel autre mais qu'on s'y aventure un
peu et on y découvrira cette chapelle
une vierge bien connu à sainte suzanne
mais bertin leti l'otan est ce que vous
savez qu'ils étaient bertin non je
savais le monsieur b atom il habitait là
bas près de la poche ya une plaque à
l'école sur son nom comme je suis pas
d'ici
conclut alors donc j'en ai entendu
parler mais c'est tout tout s'est passé
mais je voulais pas je suis pour bédié
ce coin là vous n'aurez que m non là je
sais que c'est un écrivain d'hathaway
antoine de bertin est né à sainte
suzanne en 1752
c'est avec son ami evariste de parny
qu'il part pour la france à l'âge de 9
ans brillante élève à la plume fine il
suit pourtant les voeux de son père et
entre au régiment d'artois depuis 1770
il brûle d'amour pour une femme de cinq
ans son aîné et marié de surcroît
catherine sanctuary c'est dans cette
liaison impossible qu'il puise son
inspiration il idéalise sous le nom de
caris & lui dédiera 38 élégie en 1773 la
reine marie-antoinette remarque son
almanach des muses
quatre ans plus tard sort une plaquette
dédiait son ami de parny le voyage en
bourgogne puis c'est les pitres à des
forges boucher ancien gouverneur des
îles de français de bourbon mais aussi
son parrain une oeuvre qui s'efface
derrière les poésie érotique de son ami
et varicent antoine de bertin brûlent la
vie par les deux bouts
il boit il fréquente des filles de
petite vertu il dépense sans compter
celui que la reine a promu écuyer du
comte d'artois se ruinent la sentry et
quand il apprend la mort de katherine sa
bien aimée en 1788
le coup est rude aussitôt après la
révolution l'obligent à quitter paris
pour saint-domingue
là il est sur le point d'épouser hélène
de lestang une jeune créole rencontré
dans la capitale
mais il tombe subitement malade il meurt
du typhus quelques jours plus tard il
n'avait que 38 ans
diot